we all knew our pets got up to some
weird stuff right secret life of pets
I'm just gonna say right now guys
normally I try and do the animation
focus episode like maybe once a month on
too much more often than that they're
gonna kind of come in rapid succession
that wasn't planned it's just kind of
gonna be what happens I saw Batman bad
blood I've got that review coming out
The Killing Joke is coming out soon
there's this that you know I there's a
lot of anime stuff going on it's just
what's happening but anyways this is the
latest offering from illumination now if
you don't know that name there the
studio behind despicable me and the
minions who you either love or are sick
to death of so the question is is
illumination able to move out of the
despicable me comfort zone into
something a little bit different a
little bit I was kind of say more
real-world but it's not really i'll kind
of come back to that but how does it
hold up honestly it's pretty good it's
not great but it is good it's solid it's
fun it's energetic there's some great
slapstick which illumination really
excels at i mean obviously the minions
that's did that slapstick at its
broadest and most basic but it works and
it does really well now as far as story
goes it deals in a broad sense with you
know what do your pets get it up to when
you're not home when you go to work when
you go to school whatever so it's
starting from that premise and it deals
i did set in New York City it deals with
a dog named Max whose owner has brought
in a new dog kind of a rescue dog named
Duke who is very big very slobbery very
not something that max wants in his home
and there is friction between the two of
them they end up on the street need to
try and find a way home that's your
basic storyline and basically the movie
it's at its best when it sticks to its
premise that the title implies which is
what are your pets up to when you're not
around most of the best cleverest
moments joke scenes etc spawn out of
that you know as the pet sort of moved
from one apartment to another to see
each other to hang out there's an old
dog whose owner is almost never home and
his is like the hop in place to be
because you can do anything stuff like
that is funny as clever there's a lot of
care
in this I personally kind of liked Chloe
the cat cuz I just very cat attitude I'm
a dog person in reality but the cat was
hilarious and I love just her nonchalant
said she has a great line said look I
say this as your friend I don't care
about you or your problems I'm like yep
that's a cat but all the dogs are good
do the fun too but what ends up sort of
taking over the story is this more over
the top I get basically wants the rabbit
the character of snowball shows up the
thing kind of goes in an odd direction
and I'm not really going to consider
this a spoiler because if you've seen
really any of the trailers you know that
this is in there that there's sort of
this your society of lost or forgotten
or abandoned pets sort of led by
snowball and they have a vendetta
against humanity and it's it's just a
little bit too much that there was more
than enough stuff to mind when you know
just trying to get you know Max and Duke
home they didn't need to bring in this
more outlandish element which brings in
stuff that kind of breaks the reality of
it cuz like i said the cleverest stuff
all fits within the idea of hey you know
it's cartoonish sure but that sort of
thing could happen when i'm not around
but then this whole other plot brings in
this other stuff like that's a little
much but I kind of like with finding
Dory the faults that I find with this
the target audience aren't not gonna
find with this I took my daughter that
she loved it she loved absolutely
everything about it so this is again the
adult you know critical mind looking at
children's entertainment but you know I
am still going to judge it as the kind
of person I am and you know these are
things that I kind of wish they hadn't
done or you know they could have
adjusted and also like most other
illumination projects if they have a
sort of toilet humor joke they'll hint
at it and it's kind of funny then
they'll say it outright about five
seconds later is like yeah okay we got
it before or at least I did again my
much younger child laughed her head off
when they did that so yeah again they
clearly know their audience that's why
minions makes a billion dollars but this
is not minions with animals even though
it has a lot of the same kind of humor
has a whole lot of slapstick there's a
ton of characters like to the point that
I all
would think are there too many
characters except they're all really
visually distinctive not necessarily
sure they all have distinctive
personalities but you know they're all
funny and energetic enough that you
don't mind that there's a lot of them
but just if for no other reason that's
certainly never visually boring with how
many of them there are so overall this
was a good fun time I like I said my
daughter loved it you as an adult being
dragged to this by your child you will
not feel like you need to blow your
brains out and if you are an adult who
enjoys the art of animation it is worth
seeing it is fun it's not transcendent
in any way but not everything needs to
be and with a summer as dreary and
fulham crud as we've had honestly the
sort of light palette cleanser type of
thing I'll gladly take it so that's the
secret life of pets have you seen it
what were your thoughts on it whatever
they were drop something down in the
comments and let's talk about it please
give a like subscribe follow me on
twitter at council of geeks check out
the council of geeks podcasts on iTunes
and stitcher and as for me I'll be back
as soon as I can get my next fix